bonjour à tous je vous souhaite la
bienvenue dans cette vidéo où nous
allons parler du film the marvels je
préfère le dire dès maintenant mais bien
évidemment je vais devoir spoil le film
ainsi que sa scène postgénérique si nous
voulons traiter des éléments qui ont été
apportés donc vous êtes prévenu alors
que dire sur the marvels je vous avoue
que le but de nos vidéos d'aprèsfilm ne
s'oriente pas vers un but critique je
suis curieux de voir votre ressenti en
commentaire concernant ce dernier mais
ce qui va vraiment nous intéressé ici
c'est plus le contenu le pourquoi du
comment voir les références et surtout
bah voir ce vers quoi nous nous dirigons
pour l'avenir pour être tout à fait
honnête je trouve que the marvels est un
film cahier des charges comme j'aime les
appeler c'est-à-dire une production qui
doit être là pour justifier pour
agrémenter le L pour mettre au niveau
que ce soit des personnages des concepts
et voilà cela s'arrête un peu là un peu
à la manière d'un htman 2 à l'époque qui
servait fait à justifieré la non
présence du héros dans Infinity war
ainsi qu'amener la clé du voyage dans le
temps d'Avengers game le champ quantique
ou bien même tout simplement Secret
Invasion dont l'un des buts principaux
était finalement de nous dire les scrull
depuis 30 ans il se passe quoi de leur
côté bref ici the marvels sert
premièrement à mettre Kamala et Monica
Rambo au devant de la scène c'est
peut-être idiot à dire comme ça mais le
film leur a permis de passer du petit au
grand écran elles viennent de passer de
séries à film soit les grandes
productions de Marvel nous avons eu
leurs origin story nous les avons eu au
second plan désormais on doit affirmer
les personnages et les intégrer
véritablement je pense qu'il est bon de
le rappeler mais nous sommes dans une
période de relève les Avengers se sont
arrêtés avec endgame la phase 4 a servi
à intégrer énormément de personnages de
concept et tout ce qui va avec désormais
il faut installer ces éléments et les
ancrer pour dé clencher les prochains
événements et rassemblements et ensuite
de l'autre côté il y a clairement l'idée
principale qu'il faut faire avancer
Carol Denvers et lui donner une
direction et par conséquent cela
concerne aussi tout Le Lore qui va avec
le personnage je suis vraiment dans de
la vie un petit peu personnelle pour le
moment mais Captain Marvel c'est huge
comme personnage dans les comics c'est
vraiment une entité forte elle a ce côté
militaire elle a ce côté puissant ce
côté prendre des décisions difficiles
chose que l'on retrouve justement au
moment du sauvetage des screull réfugié
sur Tarnax pendant le film et justement
ce qui manque à Carole pour Brayer tu as
compris le jeune mot c'est cet aspect
team et qui a été un élément central du
film le personnage est trop puissant et
trop solitaire et Marvel studio souhaite
changer ça c'est le but ils veulent
faire de Captain Marvel une une entité
importante de l'univers des films il n'y
a qu'à voir les dernières productions
depuis la fin d'Infinity war Carole
s'est de nouveau tourner vers la terre
principalement elle commence tout
doucement à coopérer avec les Avengers
dans endgame elle est appelée par Wong
dans shangchi pour trouver des
explications concernant les 10 Anau au
côté de Bruce Banner l'univers 838 nous
a ramener une captaine Marvel au sein
des Illuminati Illuminati qui je le
rappelle est un regroupe ouement des
héros les plus puissants et influents de
la Terre nous avons des représentants de
communauté ou d'endroits spécifiques et
captaine Marvel c'est le cosmos donc
c'est bien pour nous rappeler à quel
point le personnage est puissant et
important et nous n'avons même pas
encore parlé de la scène postgénérique
de the marvels quand on regarde les
productions rares ont été les films ou
séries à nous présenter des variants de
personnages ils l'ont fait pour Doct
strange dont nous savons l'importance au
sein de thématiques comme le multivers
ils l'ont fait pour Loki dont le
personnage est clairement devenu
centrale dans cette nouvelle phase avec
le TVA mais tout doucement ils le font
aussi pour Captain Marvel histoire de
bien nous montrer et nous prouver
qu'importe les univers Captain Marvel
est impliqué parmi les héros concernés
surtout qu'en plus ces deux variante
travaill dans des équipes je ne sais pas
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire mais
ils veulent faire de captaine Marvel
pourquoi pas une des prochaines figures
emblématiques de la prochaine team de
super-héros possiblement une sorte de
leader surtout que elle a désormais
crevé l'abset et réparé ce qu'elle a
fait avec l'Empire cri de quoi lui
permettre dorénavant de pleinement
revenir sur Terre en quelque sorte
surtout que en plus l'empereur scrull et
ses réfugiés sont à partir de maintenant
à newasgard bref tout est fait pour
tourner Carol Denvers vers une position
de leader ou du moins de coopération en
team et la libéré de ses poids pour
qu'elle retourne plus sur la terre
ensuite il faut un petit peu parler de
l'Empire cri chose que j'attendais entre
guillemets de ce film quand il avait été
annoncé c'était à la fois nous montrer
une faiblesse concernant Carole
c'est-à-dire nous montrer que quand bien
même elle est surpuissante et
indestructible rien ne l'autorise à
jouer à la divinité et forcément au bout
d'un moment ça allait se retourner
contre elle carole a diminuer l'Empire
cri beaucoup trop même et justement cela
amène par rebondissement l'autre point
que j'attendais du film Les concernant
c'est la revalorisation si je puis dire
de ce peuple en fait l'écrit c'est une
sacrée communauté dans les comics c'est
vraiment un peuple dur un peuple de
guerriers de conquérents entre
guillemets ils sont très puissants ils
influencent beaucoup la galaxie ils ont
donné naissance et conçu énormément
d'artefacts voire même des civilisations
avec leur savoir et leurs expériences et
on retrouve un peu ça notamment dans le
film avec les bracelets ils ont même
énormément assauvi ou colonisé il y a
notamment ce délire d'accusateur une
entité crie équipée de l'arme
universelle qui va guider le peuple et
faire respecter la loi et les souhaits
de l'intelligence suprême comme Ronan à
l'époque des gardien ici darben a repris
ce rôle et l'inspiration on en avait
parlé bah c'est le général darben des
comics mais qui est complètement
anecdotique là-bas néant moins malgré
tout ça l'écrit reste un peuple comme
les autres avec des femmes avec des
enfants avec des habitants qui sont très
patriotiques c'est dans leur culture
mais cela n'en fait pas des antagonistes
pour autant et avant the marvels les
cris était véritablement dépint comme
des vilains contrairement au scrull qui
eux étaient tous des victimes sauf que
ce n'était pas véritablement juste et
cela ne correspond pas à l'essence du
conflit cri scrull qui est une guerre
interminable des comics Secret Invasion
a justement servi à nous montrer en
partie qu'il pouvait y avoir du mauvais
chez les scrull et il fallait que the
marvels pour rééquilibrer nous montre
qu'il n'y a pas que du mauvais chez les
cris histoire d'inverser un peu par
rapport au premier film Captain Marvel
bref pour continuer il faut que nous
fassions un petit point sur les
bracelets de Kamala car nous avons eu de
nouvelles révélations les concernants on
avait supposé à l'époque que c'est
dernier s'apparentaiit au bracelets liés
à la zone négative des bracelets qui
permettent de switch de place notamment
avec une autre personne en possession de
l'autre paire de bracelets car oui dans
les comics il y a deux paires finalement
Carole nous a révélé qu'il s'agissait
des bracelet quantique c'est un artefact
qui a longuement été utilisé par Captain
Marvel dans les comics et le MCU a
totalement repris leur fonctionnement
les bracelets permettent la création de
construction quantique très semblable au
pouvoir de Kamala et peuvent notamment
permettre à son porteur de traverser
l'espace-temps avec la création de trou
de vert dans l'espace néanmoins je
trouve qu'il y a deux éléments très
intéressants à relever concernant les
bracelets dans le MCU bon déjà Carole
les a reconnu et a su mettre un nom
instantanément sur ces derniers les
bracelets sont des artefacts anciens
issu de légende et pourtant Carole qui
est experte de l'espace et du cosmos les
a reconnu du coup bah j'ai envie de dire
qu'en est-il des di anneau je trouve que
the marvels permet d'appuyer encore plus
le mystère autour des dianneau car
Carole n'arrive pas à les reconnaître
elle n'arrive même pas à reconnaître le
matériaux dont ils sont faits donc il y
a clairement sujet à théorie et ensuite
et bien vu que Kamala a désormais les
deux bracelets elle va pouvoir ouvrir un
portail vers la dimension Nour puisque
dans sa série un seul bracelet
permettait d'ouvrir un portail mais très
instable et impraticable au point de
devenir même dangereux ce sera donc
peut-être le moment d'intégrer pourquoi
pas un nouveau peuple dans le MCU et
rentrer une fois de plus dans le concept
de dimension un concept important et qui
nous a été ramené à plusieurs reprises
notamment via Doct strange mais on ne
peut rien affirmer actuellement en
revanche les bracelets vont pouvoir
servir d'upgrade pour Kamala car le film
nous a révélé une fonction particulière
concernant ces derniers ils tirent leur
pouvoir de la dimension Nour leur
dimension d'origine c'est assez logique
cela reprend en fait le principe de base
que nous expliquait l'ancien dans
docteor Strange c'est que des héros
comme bah strange notamment utilise
l'énergie issue d'autres dimensions du
multivers pour effectuer des sortilèges
ou du moins ce genre de chose mais pour
aller encore plus loin Nour signifiant
lumière il semble clair que seul un
utilisateur relié à l'utilisation de
pouvoir liés à la lumière puisse
véritaableblement utiliser les deux
bracelets ce qui explique pourquoi
Kamala les utilise à la fin du film pour
charger Monica alors que darben s'est
autodétruite de son côté ne pouvant
encaisser autant d'énergie d'ailleurs je
le reprécise ici pour celles et ceux qui
pourrait avoir un doute mais les
bracelets ont simplement réveillé les
pouvoirs de Miss Marvel puis que ces
dernières possède en elle un gène mutant
et pour appuyer du coup ce qu'on vient
de dire Kamala n'est pas la seule à
utiliser les bracelets quantique c'est
également le cas de Maria Rambo présente
dans la scène postgénérique quelle belle
transition pour parler de ce qui vous
intéresse certainement tous ici lors du
combat final d'ben à force de créer des
points de saut à travers l'espace-temps
va créer celui de trop avant de mourir
déchirant le tissu de la réalité
découlant donc sur une ouverture vers
une réalité adjacente à la nôtre la 616
Monica va donc faire le choix de se
bloquer dans l'autre univers afin de
reformer le tissu et éviter pourquoi pas
une incursion soit la collision de deux
univers provoquant la destruction de ces
deux derniers et après avoir perdu
connaissance Monica va se faire
recueillir par des héros de cet univers
alternatif et nous faisons la découverte
d'une Maria Rambo variante et d'un fauve
des X-Men bon je ne vais pas vous mentir
il faudra qu'on creuse un petit peu plus
la question et la scène
postgénérique mais pour moi actuellement
elle est plus symbolique qu'autre chose
à mes yeux déjà tout simplement car la
question d'incursion a été évitée Monica
a réparer la réalité en se bloquant dans
l'autre univers et par extension bloquer
Monica dans une autre réalité cela
permet de ramener encore une fois le
concept de multivers qui est le sujet
principal de ce nouveau cycle ces
nouvelles phases ensuite il y a
également la présence d'Henry Hank McCoy
le fauve avec le même acteur de l'époque
nous savons que c'est un personnage qui
a été rajouté un petit peu au dernier
moment et le but ici est clairement fan
service ce qui n'est pas mauvais en soi
c'est très cool le fan service mais du
coup pour moi ici cela sert simplement à
nous montrer bah l'existence des X-Men
les tant attendu X-Men qui ont été enfin
racheté par Marvel studio à la Fox en
réalité ce que je trouve le plus
intéressant dans cette scène
postgénérique c'est binary effectivement
Maria Rombo dans cet univers reprend
l'apparence de Binary des comics une
sorte de Captain Marvel alternative qui
d'ailleurs a déjà combattu au côté des
X-Men mais petite précision à l'origine
binary n'est pas vraiment humaine c'est
une création un peu involontaire de
captaine Marvel c'est un concentré de
pouvoir et de lumière qui ont pris forme
humanoïde je vous le dis pour votre
savoir comme ça hein c'est notre petit
point comics mais en réalité du coup
Binar dans le MCU reprend simplement le
nom et le costume du personnage l'idée
ici avec binary c'est plutôt d'amener
encore une fois une variante de captaine
Marvel si Maria Rambo a des pouvoirs et
qu'elle devient captaine Marvel et bien
c'est qu'elle a pris la place de Carolle
Denvers durant l'explosion
supraluminique et petit détail qui
d'ailleurs vient appuyer tout ça c'est
qu'elle est en possession des bracelets
quantiques de son univers qui comme je
vous l'ai dit peuvent être pleinement
utilisés par des êtres liés à la lumière
et c'est le cas de Captain Marvel vous
le savez donc voilà et enfin petit mot
concernant les Young Avengers évidemment
grâce aux informations secrètes de cyber
récupéré par Kamala cette dernière a
accès au au profil de certains jeunes
personnages qui ont été introduits dans
de précédentes productions elle part
donc à la rencontre de Kate Bishop une
figure emblématique de l'équipe dans les
comics et la raison est plutôt simple
elle est la plus âgée des membres donc
la plus mature en quelque sorte il y a
la mention de la fille de scottl Cassi
qui elle aussi fait partie des Young
Avengers là-bas mais à voir comment le
MCU adaptera tout ça ce qui est
intéressant c'est que normalement les
Young Avengers est une équipe conçue est
dirigé par Iron lad la jeune version de
Kang le conquérant qui souhaite faire le
bien et battre son lui adulte ici c'est
Kamala qui est à l'initiative à voir ce
que prépare le MCU nous aurons
l'occasion de faire des vidéos dédiées
sur le sujet car il y a plein d'éléments
intéressants à dire mais il ne faudra
pas s'attendre à voir l'équipe des
comics c'est sûr pour moi patriote Billy
et Tommy il y a de grandes chances qu'on
les ait dans l'équipe nous serions face
du coup à un groupe de 6 comme les
Avengers d'origine mais à voir America
Chavez pourrait les rejoindre même si
elle est un petit peu dans une autre
catégorie dans le MCU kill loky par
contre vu qu'ils l'ont utilisé dans le
loky et en plus ils l'ont placé dans le
void comme un Variant je pense que l'on
peut faire une croix dessus dans tous
les cas personnellement j'espère de tout
cœur qu'ils adapteront children's
Crusade car c'est très clairement pour
moi le meilleur arc concernant les Young
Avengers dans les comics pour le moment
il y a moyen avec ça de parler de Kang
de Wanda bref si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur cet événement de fou des comics
je vous conseille ma vidéo dédiée à la
Sorcière Rouge pourquoi Wanda Maximov
est si unique et voilà pour le moment je
vous propose que l'on s'arrête ici nous
pourrons redétailler certains sujets à
l'avenir n'hésitez pas si vous avez des
questions ce genre de truc je ne sais
pas ce que vous avez pensé du film de
votre côté n'hésitez pas à le partager
en commentaire mais dans le respect hein
bien évidemment et comme je vous disais
bah n'hésitez pas pas si vous voulez
faire remonter quelque chose par rapport
à the marvels s'il y a des choses dont
vous aimeriez qu'on parle n'oubliez pas
le petit pouce bleu et à vous abonner
c'était targoroc ciao tout le
[Musique]
monde